[Musica]
[Applauso]
sono all'estero
il cervello in fuga e prima lista è il
mio percorso
volevo citare stimolare la mia ragazza
adesso come immaginerete non è facile
partire meriti parte ovviamente la
richiesta e pensione sul morale ho
pensato di farle un regalo ma non avevo
completamente idea di cosa regalarle
così oggi sta intorno a me mica l'ho
chiesto di fare la pesca e dalle karl è
questa la mia vacanza
il consiglio di una borsa da magari ce
cascano nella trappola totalmente le
makwan se fossi the cover è senza ombra
di dubbio questa borsa ovviamente il
negozio è un contrato senza ombra di
dubbio questa box ho fatto il
pacchettino carino scritto la case
romantica che lo lasciavano soletta è
una modella stanno aspettando
un'associazione che puntualmente
arrivata ed è stata questa nostra
bellissima
adesso sei qualcuno di voi penso che
questo è saputo reale
alziamo sono infatti dominato perché
effettivamente questo è un brutto regalo
pessimo regalo è il messaggio
in effetti consegnavano questa pasta è
perfetta per un'amica non per lei
se ci pensate lei usa la maschera la
nottata ai gusti della mitica ma li
aveva detto
the complete questa cosa ma ovviamente
non era lei guidato fallita questo
regalo adesso giochiamo molto questa
storia
questa storia a capire quanto sia
difficile fare i regali è così ti dice
pare reali che nemmeno di fronte
arriviamo in appalto vuole o almeno una
parte qualche ragazzo live view ha
capito che questo regalo ma non sono qui
per fatto padelli per offendere
obiettivi
pensate di fare regali da sicuro se la
chiamo tutti e pensiero anche sul morale
proprio dimostrare con frank rom ed è
oggi parliamo è che tutti quanti
cerchiamo in silli ormai non stiamo a
fare i regali
quindi cosa facciamo andiamo su google e
scriviamo cosa posso regalare in effetti
preparasi veramente cosa corso dei
suggerimenti bene cosa posso richiamare
da chiarimento che cercano nel cosa
possa regalare al mio ragazzo che per
qualche motivo più difficile ma lei è
una ragazza quella del settarismo e
nascosta pensa tester honda transalp
altrimenti avete un complimento da fare
secondo problema è che nonostante ci
mettiamo a cercare online crediti e le
piene del multiplo assicuro farina non
solo io con le porte a tutti quanti ho
molti noi tagliamo i tre legali e se
volete una prova che dimostra questa
cosa a narrare si sono tuffati quando
riusciamo chiaramente al bagno sul tavo
andiamo
abbiamo una lista di giornata online
troviamo siccome questo come riciclare i
regali nizzi abbiamo certo adesso sono
sicuro che molti poi magari ho avuto
questo problema ma vi sconsiglio
caldamente di andare i giusti silvio a
nome di meno legali a meno che come
vedete internet nostre telecamere queste
ragazze quindi no quale noi siamo
questa è la triste se vogliamo siamo
anche se economica
lo sappiamo che stiamo parlando
complimenti di fuga di cervelli proprio
per poi escono tutti sono sotto lo
diciamo ma nonostante tutto ci vorrei
aloqa guardate ha continuato a salire
salire nelle mente negli ultimi
vent'anni fa di questa antica adesso
parlano poi deve nominare amiche rivali
perché vent'anni fa non esistevano ma
adesso prodotto è sempre esistito è in
un altro lato crisi no sono impone
regalo imponete che non siamo così
negati nel file e ai che avevamo
provveduto è qualla mazzarona solo tu
perché io non ne vale chi sta bene ma
c'è un ma perché non è altro e fatelo
con questi soldi in questo posto è il
gioco scoperto il risultato veramente
triste che l'anno scorso nei soli stati
uniti un miliardo di dollari di buoni
regalo non sono mai stati utilizzati
quindi non è un bel regalo che tagliate
con hanno perso
adesso non sono più solamente per questa
cosa ma voglio continuare la mia storia
è ovviamente sono andato all'estero
è legato al dito da single quindi maiale
quando sia importante fare regali e io
che sul proprio percorso di ricerca
io sono un giocatore sul cancro ma ha
avuto la fortuna di conoscere alle
persone agli italiani perché ben in fuga
riconosciuto fratello anche all'estero
che si occupa la sicurezza online oppure
vittorio che tenta di ridurre le
emissioni di anidride carbonica forse
stavano per i problemi più gravi della
nostra generazione e nonostante dai
nostri momenti occupate risolvere questo
impegnano le menti che si occupava di
potere l'umanità
nessuno di noi era in grado di
rispondere ad una semplicissima e
banalissima domanda come si fa a bergamo
come si fa
sembra scontavano nessuno posate ram e
allora vai a chi come abbiamo anche
spiegato che sembravano persone che non
si sono fermate quante limiti ma
bellitti quali motivi di programmatici
culturali persone che non hanno trovato
ostacoli e noi abbiamo altri tutti siamo
all'estero ci siamo occupati più di
reali possiamo risolvere questo problema
per farlo abbiamo chiesto ai nostri
amici e conoscenti di rispondere a delle
semplicissime domande qual è il regalo
più bello o più brutto che avessero
ricevuto di descriverlo
in questo modo siamo riusciti a capire
quali sono le caratteristiche in comune
dei regali in effetti quindi avevano
tutti bei regali ma che mancava
ovviamente nemico di tutti una vita
occupate sono piu per kylie 0 30 questo
è un problema però caratteristica non è
salone ma la storia che riguarda nè le
sorelle francesca valeria adesso valeria
è la classica vacanza alla grazia
ma non mi piace tutta la nazione io non
so se vuoi conoscere personalmente non
sto mai tipo di ragazza che lo mette 12
e cocktail di tutto ovviamente
immaginate come ha chiesto il fidanzato
mentre tante corse trova questo sapore
di trazione idea criminale lo contro le
marche una sorpresa non conta su per
soddisfare tale tema casa e di non la
roba
quindi la stessa fortuna mia ormai
riesce a vantarsi di questi minuti di
aver fatto bene a tutto qua mentre
eravamo noi
le rimane kamata e di palermo la sua
scrivania anche le chiede ma il modo per
limite puzzo cosa che ultimamente dove
devo dire che il reato è un messaggio
il paradosso dei pardi calo e che ne
sappiamo se vogliamo ambire gente regalo
ma non avete arti cose perché la anche
lo riceve quindi se vogliamo assicurarci
che chi diceva lega lo capisca dobbiamo
sottolineare stressare lo abbiamo
effettivamente per capire qual è il
significato un esempio più rapido fate
capire l'importanza di questo tipo
strano registica mangiate in volete
dimostrare la stima verso qualcuno ad
esempio stima essere posto sindaco
assolutamente i nonni intestate lì una
polizza vita non lo fare lezione
potrebbe essere che percorre le vie
legali
quindi quando
dovrebbe essere chiaro dell'inizio
significa andiamo avanti però seconda
storia seconda coppia è stata portata a
scuole e stella la squadra ragazzo a
passerò la palestra fitness che la sta
tenteranno di taglio guardate le partite
stella vogliamo composto alla casta
molto alla moda e degli stessi bene
comune di pasquale stella finalmente
alla sua occasione che conta questa
camicia quando amici ha più la classica
moles di noi andiamo a casa
lo squalene c'era velocemente stavolta
stella differenti di francesco
sottolinea il saio impazzire all'idea di
vedere far gustare tutti i chiodi è
definitivamente dal sicuro che questa
capisce il progetto sta davanti toni
dalle parti mas quale non mancano i
conti anche alle camicie noi aveva
perché non è mossa qual è il merito di
questa sul canale di ispiranti di
prescrizione ovviamente regalo non è per
noi e per chi lo riceve un regalo tanto
bene e cavalli wow
dobbiamo adeguarci ai gusti dei cenette
cose che arrivavano altri ad esempio con
la borsa è anche la mia ragazza
quante se ne fa uso da capire quanto è
importante questo è questa
caratteristica
se ci riesco ad esempio è il papa appena
insediatasi palamara tour in sudamerica
è visto sud america
sapete il bigliettino quando papà sidari
di una serie tra la politica e
quest'estate lolita si presentano con
questo regalo di padroni un crocifisso
forma di falce e martello
adesso capite sebbene per molti
sembra in palio e anche per me ma non
regale in crocifissa prova insieme a te
non è giusto prendere fiducia come
vedere una bolla e il presidente della
napoli e poi anche la roma stavolta
cambia la lega l'ha capito la lezione e
le regala puntati su al qaeda è stato
eletto per la sua capacità di fare
regali o due legni prima storia ultima
notte stavo qualche una coppia di
fratelli parla modicano e dice che dice
ah no l'idea di passare in your man è
un'idea originale hanno fatto sapere che
speriamo altro una per andare negli
occhi quel metodo
quindi se non avete soldi non accada
tutto alcantara ovviamente ma tutte le
norme che conoscono ma la stessa regalo
50 tiri poveri al posto anche carol e
non farei la finisco sapevano e quando
sono andate a prelevare il layout poco
prima della terza alla nostra aperto che
la una bellanca bella idea quella ha
deciso di fare propri regali
ovviamente inizialmente avevamo presa
benissimo matematica con 51 quando dice
la sorella maria de cao vedevano nostri
sensi ovviamente è un decalogo della
marmi e per tutti i nipoti cavola
risparmiamo anche sfondo gli sci che le
regalo e lo darò c'era una volta di york
e poi c'è la chiama cavallo
giallo riguarda questo pensiero ma le
cravatte sono proprio le testine adesso
regalo una scena del sesto le nipoti
donne è una chiamata per i nipoti maschi
di questa storia è daniela ma in cambio
nell'idiota ma con le maniere che non ci
sono scorciatoie con un regalo per un
regalo che si vede più tecniche stiamo
per fare un regalo
milano è strana e lega faccia subito per
vedere quali sono le caratteristiche di
capitana primo regalo di messaggi ha un
significato
dovete scrivere a dirlo è ciò che
regalati dei veramente in tanti
significati seconda caratteristica il
regalo non è per mobbing e per chi lo
riceve quindi adeguate i miei gusti alla
situazione all'occasione ad una poca
medico la persona e si occupava niente
di niente di niente e adesso anche
raiano vale più il tempo mi spiegate che
non i soldi alle 6 sono sicuro che cosi
che vi sto dicendo per poi mai chi siamo
veramente campate in aria
sono sicuro che è dentro di noi sapeva
bene che queste cose potevano essere
bene e mi assicuro che noi sappiamo
famiglia e bianchi siamo mai stata
regalo famoso del mondo quale era una
famosa al mondo
qualcuno che sarà eletto il cavallo di
[ __ ]
adesso questo era un regalo che non
poteva apparire lei doveva assicurarsi
che i doriani pene destra un serial che
cosa hanno fatto per assicurarsi
gli animi alessi questo legame prima a
tutti si sono nascosti del cavallo nelle
navi hanno lasciato il povero
disgraziato lì assieme al cavallo perché
doveva dire il significato di questo
regalo o vedere messaggio doveva rivali
piano ai doriani non potevamo lasciare
ogni caso qual era il nostro messaggio
che il povero di scalzare doveva dire
era qui siamo ci ha riso plastico e
tutti i classicissimi per le donne runs
detto ma ricavata presenta una
benedizione di alena che se vogliamo è
la più i troiani volevano e che mancava
loro non è che gli hanno dato qualcosa
che viene meno
sono andati a scegliere cosa che più di
tutti desideravano e infine pensava ci
hanno fatto un cavallo di legno
vogliamo regalare loro delle armi
una soluzione veloce si sono messi
subito un enorme cavallo di legno
santori del tour della tavassi ma avete
quando a sera con extra legge ma nessuno
si sorprende che i nojani alla beta m a
anzi sospettiamo di tutti la crema del
frais l'update stasi per quanti sono
stati perché mi sto dicendo questa
storia di autorizzare un appello a
quello poi a questa occasione che fanno
appello sebbene significava con quelle
cose abbiamo scherzato su
i regali sono importanti addirittura a
proporre il sistema che si sa bene fare
regali è una caratteristica che generi
domani probabilmente una differenza tra
gli animali superiori quelli inferiori e
protetti bassi l'inps e le cose di
partecipanti
quindi non è una cosa da niente una cosa
molto importante e noi stiamo
paralizzarla che sta facendo attualmente
non dobbiamo ridurre il regalo un buono
regalo
siccome cosa molto importante per favore
dobbiamo impegnarci non facciamo noi
tendiamo a questa nostra utilità ma
dovremo fare derivano i migliori grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]